hello I am Nina dating dating dating oh
my god it's so boring call you you want
to hear about all the embarrassing
stories like that time I had spinach in
my teeth or my tampon fell out mid kiss
okay um Carrie listen I'm moving to LA
can you put my shows there at what you
must be Nina this place is beautiful
I need trees around me I'm water-based
so I need the balance
I'm whisky based that's more my thing
uh um Rafe I'm not gonna sleep with you
just take it one step at a time okay I'm
no longer married I was she broke my
heart you keep being honest what's the
matter with you hey Nina
they're gonna give one lucky lady their
own one-hour special three
impersonations got it
Nina this is selling deal it's just
sheer talking to you right now I'll
believe in you the next one is Jabba the
[ __ ]
I met somebody didn't you say you're
gonna make me do that say make you
dinner
I meant order it's funny sexy and just
the right amount of screwed up hey what
are you what are you doing here
wait don't leave don't leave no no way
no so this is what you want you want men
fighting over you that you know
the truth will set you free what if the
truth send you to jail people seem to
think I'm negative Oh watch it [ __ ] not
the type of girl you'd want to bring
home it's a brand new world now what's
the real you
[Music]
all in all I think of a reasonably good
person oh thank you
[Applause]
you